movies were foreign to us like my dad I
think he took me to one movie in my my
whole life it was funny it was Indiana
Jones came out I think I was like 10 I
didn't know what it was because it said
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom but
it sounded like Raiders a lost Arc it
was rers a lost Arc right and it's I
thought it was like a movie about The
Bible so I cried and was like I want to
see Annie so my dad took me to see Annie
and he fell asleep and I watched Little
Orphan Annie and that was like the first
movie I ever watched it was like was 10
cuz I didn't go to the movies you know
yeah um so so telling them I want to be
an actor was like uh tell them I want to
go to Mars it was just like but after
you did a movie with a bunch of
Empires no I think that they come on no
cuz here's the thing my they don't
understand the world of it so when I go
home you know my mom's more interested
in like why aren't you eating you know I
mean eat your pasta like you're getting
too skinny eat this like so it's like
the blessing of my parents are they
would love me no matter what I did